[Music]
hi this is Mike I was just calling to
see if that job that you offered was
still available yes
security guard I won't take anything
this place was huge in the 80s with the
kids they shut it down years ago the
owner's just not ready to let it go yet
I will work and you will sleep I
understand
all you have to do
is keep your eyes on the monitor
welcome to Freddy Fazbear's where
fantasy and
[Music]
[Applause]
we must be new security guards can I
help you officer have you met them yet
bam
[Music]
foreign
kids went missing
the police searched Freddy's top to
bottom hello
they never found them
that's why the place shut down
there are ghost children possessing
giant robots
thanks for the heads up
technically they're animatronics
what do they want they want to make her
like them puppy
tell me how to stop them
it's too late
where to
I don't always get the weirdos
[Music]
foreign